emmanuel macron l'avait dit lors d'une
de ses allocutions c'est dur d'avoir 20
en 2020 une phrase qui résonne davantage
avec l'actualité de ces dernières
semaines et la détresse affiché de
plusieurs étudiants qui ont mis fin à
leurs jours
détruit par leur situation difficile
l'impossibilité de vivre pleinement leur
vie de jeunes ou d'envisager un avenir
quelconque si le sort des commerçants ou
l'univers de la culture est
régulièrement au coeur des débats
celui d'une jeunesse abandonnée ne sont
pas intéressé grand monde comme si seule
l'économie était le problème dans cette
crise sanitaire
sans oublier qu'en plus de cette
incapacité à vivre leur jeunesse de
nombreux étudiants se retrouvent sans
travail et donc sans ressources pour
payer leur logement ou leurs frais de
scolarité donjon dans une précarité
aussi inquiétante que soudaine suicide
dans out précarité silence autour d'une
jeunesse en détresse ce soir l'eau
nageant deux étudiants sont avec nous
pour mettre en lumière la jeunesse face
à la crise actuelle et merci à oyonnax
et merci à jean d'être avec nous il y en
a 22 ans étudiante en master à paris
merci d'être là merci beaucoup à tous
les deux je sais que votre alors je vous
le dis le témoignage de yuna et jean il
va toucher énormément de monde que ce
soit des parents des étudiants des plus
jeunes et des plus âgés
vous sentez dans quel état aujourd'hui
de la moi personnellement je me sens en
colère en détresse triste c'est de la
situation actuelle on est oubliés on
n'est pas entendu et là on en a marre
vous êtes les grandes oubliées de cette
crise pour ou totalement notamment
pourquoi est-ce que vous avez déjà
entendu le mot étudiants dans les
allocutions dont un délit c'est vrai j'y
ai cru aujourd'hui comme yavé y avait
tout le monde je me suis dit bon il va y
avoir on va en parler c'est l'été les
nrj music awards démunis des ministres
cet après midi je me suis dit à un
moment et vous peut-être parler des
étudiants on aura peut-être des réponses
à vous donner soi non il y avait bien
jean michel blanquer
mais vous c'est vrai que vous n'avez pas
été cité les étudiants là la jeunesse
voilà c'est vrai et je crois que ça vous
rend complètement fou parce
qu'aujourd'hui vous êtes vous est
confiné chez vous dans votre appartement
votre votre quotidien c'est devenu une
angoisse totale non c'est ça on est
autour du matin au soir
ouais de 8 heures jusqu'à 18h30 19h on
enchaîne avec quoi les devoirs
c'est un quotidien fait rien d'autre on
voit personne on est tout seul d'un
écran du matin au soir c'est plus facile
alors grande écoute à 22 ans il ya de
plus en plus de dépression
c'est vrai ya plein de jeunes qui sont
des pressions de 20 22 ans 23 ans 18 ans
c'est incroyable [ __ ] mais vous vous
êtes vous avez des amis aussi qu'ils
sont comme vous qui sont dans un état de
détresse
incroyable oui j'ai pas dit que la
majorité des étudiants sont en détresse
mais un grand monde pour ma part j'ai eu
le coach deux fois donc une fois en
septembre et une fois le 24 décembre
sympa donc imaginé un étudiant en
passant les fêtes de fin d'année tout
seul sans sa famille sans rien en route
donc on est beaucoup à avoir vécu ça et
là c'est on tire la larme en fait c'est
plus facile alors dit que j'en ai trop
vous êtes quand vous dites que j'en ai
trop vous vous dites quand vous dites on
va on va arrêter de suivre les consignes
on aimerait conscient qu plus de nous
c'est quoi votre cri d'alarmé on
aimerait qu'on s'occupe plus de nous en
fait nous on fait notre maximum pour pas
décrocher on essaye de suivre nos cours
du matin au soir on essaye de bien faire
mes devoirs
on essaye à chaque 110 bon on se motive
ça va bien se passer
mais force est plus possible et voilà on
voudrait arrêter d'être oubliés on
voudrait qu'on s'intéresse à nous on
aimerait voilà qu'on nous demande aussi
notre avis parce que notre avis on
essaye de le donner on nous écoute pas
on aux expats ça passe déjà par les
universités il ya de nombreux mails pour
les partielles par exemple en présentiel
aussi pour l'insertion professionnelle
et en présentiel ça vous fait peur à
l'aller en présentiel faire vos partiel
pour ma part étant une personne à risque
oui j'ai peur pour moi j'ai peur aussi
de contaminer la famille bien sûr c'est
quelque chose qui me fait très peur
réfection alors on a également jean avec
nos étudiants en licence en sciences po
vous êtes donc en 3e année de sciences
politiques loin de votre famille à
montpellier comme beaucoup d'étudiants
vous je vous ai vu hier gens m'avaient
hier vraiment au bout du bout je sais
pas si je suis la personne la plus beau
du bon et l'étudiant le plus au bout du
bout mais c'est sûr que j'en ai marre
d'avoir passé tout ce confinement on a
commencé à faire le semestre en
présentiel se mue en présentiel 50/50 ça
marchait très bien user rocade covit
dans notre faculté de montpellier et
après on nous a mis donc le confinement
donc ça veut dire le matin on se lève
pas on reste dans notre lit on se ruine
notre ordinateur ouest en pyjama toute
la journée
parfois on objecte de louper des repas
on oublie de manger le midi donc à un
moment donné oui c'est sûr que c'est
compliqué c'est compliqué pas tous les
jours il ya des jours où ça va mieux on
essaye d'appeler la famille etc pour
aller mieux les amis on a du soutien
mais moi je pense à tous les étudiants
compas compass soutient la couleur il
paraît que pendant le 2ème confinement
vous étiez à montpellier donc loin de
votre famille et ça a été un coup de
massue ont sorti plus de votre lit assez
ça en fait je me levais le matin je me
dis ah bah je vais prendre mon p'tit déj
banal non je me disais bon chez gmg un
cours magistral directement donc en fait
je me lève pas je vais prendre juste mon
ordinateur je la lui et voilà je mets en
jeu note les cours et c'est quoi et bien
sûr j'essaie de faire des pauses mais je
reste toute la journée en pyjama quoi
c'est vraiment ça le truc vous est
arrivé de péter les plombs de dire voilà
et oui ça m'arrive et c'est sûr qu'il ya
des moments où on se demande mais
pourquoi pourquoi on nous fait subir ce
à quoi
du coup il ya des moments où vous avez
envie de taper sur un mur ou bien sûr
mais c'est ça a été très difficile et on
essaye de j'essaie de relativiser quand
même à chaque fois de me dire que ouais
que c'est pas la pire des situations il
ya des gens qui sont encore pire que moi
etc
mais c'est sûr que j'ai très dur alors
il ya beaucoup de 2,4 suicide chez les
étudiants de plus en plus ce week-end ya
un étudiant lyonnais qui a tenté de
mettre fin à ses jours en se jetant de
la fenêtre du quatrième étage de sa
chambre universitaire en france le
risque suicidaire et de 6 7% parmi la
population étudiante est de 11 pour cent
chez les étudiants en santé vous est-ce
que vous avez des amis des gens dans
votre entourage qui vous dis franchement
cette société-là on vient pas j'en peux
plus je vois pas le bout du tunnel et
qui pense au pire y en a ou un chewing
gum comme ben oui oui oui totalement là
je pense à mon école mais je pense à
toutes les écoles il ya des dizaines des
vingtaines de mail qui circule des
appels à l'aide
bon bah voilà
j'ai des idées noires mais personne ne
les écoute et je pense que c'est quelque
chose qui pourrait être totalement
éviter sur les réseaux sociaux il ya des
appels à l'aide
le gouvernement ne les entend pas sur
l'autre je suis désolé on al'impression
vraiment d'être une génération sacrifiée
quoi par le gouvernement et après il ya
des petites interventions par exemple
frédéric vidal mardi matin ça alors quoi
c'est vrai c'est un frédéric vidal
ministre de l'enseignement supérieur
s'est justement exprimé concernant le
sort des étudiants
il a fait plusieurs annonces voilà que
la reprise est là elle a fait plusieurs
annonces reprise par demi groupe en
travaux dirigés en première année dans
les universités à partir du 25 janvier
le nombre de psychologues sera doublée
dans les établissements se mettent et
les tests antigénique seront proposés
aux services de santé une des
universités
vous en pensez quoi de ces annonces
alors mois déjà une remarque à faire ça
vous fait rire j'ai un photographe oui
elle parle des premières années les
autres qu'est ce qu'on fait
effectivement les premières années ils
sont du lycée c'est dur pour eux de
décrocher constat je suis d'accord mais
on est tous dans le même cas donc
pourquoi eux et pas nous nous on est
tous pareils on est tous derrière notre
écran on aimerait retourner en cours on
en a besoin on a besoin de vendre nos
professeurs on a besoin d'eux dans nos
camarades c'est plus possible ses seins
en fait c'est déjà bien de faire ça
c'est déjà le mime et c'est le problème
c'est que c'est le minimum c'est pas
suffisant fait de dire ça doubler les
psychologues ça ça va doubler ça veut
dire qu'on lui donne à voir un en aura 2
pour 40 minutes
est ce que parce que vous trouvez que
dans les autres pays ce que vous êtes
intéressé à ce qui se passe dans les
autres pays
est ce que vous trouvez qu'on fait plus
pour la jeunesse pour les étudiants
qu'en france ou bien ce que vous dites
vraiment nous en france on est délaissé
est ce que vous avez regardé un petit
peu ce qui se passe ailleurs parce que
c'est vrai que dans cette crise elle est
mondiale et qu' il ya beaucoup
d'étudiants dans le monde entier qui
sont dans le même cas que vous alors est
ce que vous essayez pas de vous dire
voilà en réponse est vrai que ça se
passe un petit peu partout pareil ou
est-ce que certains étudiants sont mieux
lotis ailleurs yona alors moi j'ai quand
même l'impression que les étudiants des
autres pays sont quand même plus écoutez
il ya une relation déjà et que leurs
universités une relation de confiance
avec leurs gouvernements aussi et nous
allons y avait plus confiance
non vraiment non ce que vous allez être
ceux qui vont voter oui exactement
en 2022 secousse avait déjà eu l'idée
pour qui vous allez voter ou là pas du
tout encore pardon j'attends qu'on
compte quelque chose je veux des preuves
nouvelles actions un peu moins de blabla
plus d'action ça sera votre premier vote
non non c'est non merci ou non mais si
pour les premiers le présentiel oui ça
sera installé vote
résidentiel paraît que 2021 donc bon que
qu'est ce que vous avez à faire passer
comme message
s'il ya des membres du gouvernement qui
nous écoutent ou qui nous regardent on
nous laisse la parole alors déjà j'ai
envie de dire écoutez nous considérer
nous et arrêtez de nous oublier
on est là on est tous au même niveau en
fait il n'ya pas que les collégiens les
lycéens les travailleurs il ya aussi les
étudiants nous aujourd'hui on a besoin
de vous par exemple je pense à
l'insertion professionnelle
je suis désolé j'en profites en exact
c'est terrible c'est impossible entre
michel savin ce parce que les
entreprises ne veulent pas vous
embaucher parce qu'ils ont peur ici
alors que ça un apprenti sa coupe 0 en
faut le dire à des entrepreneurs qui
nous regardent ça qu'on trouve un stade
aussi fait rembourser par l'état ça
coûtera 1 jeunes écoutent ce match dans
quoi dans les relations internationales
coopération internationale à faire les
chérir ce top 10 je m'adresse à vous
tous et même à ceux qui nous regardent à
la télé je suis à la recherche d'un
stage donc si vous avez quelque chose
pour moi n'hésitez pas et je pense que
vous allez avoir de nos besoins et et
vous gens que si vous avez à dire bas
juste
comme l'a dit la digue menacé d'être
considérés d'être écouté et pas
seulement de nous faire des petites
phrases aux mots de ses dires c'est dur
de remporter en 2020 quoi c'est vraiment
de du concret de d'essayer de travailler
avec les étudiants clairement pour pour
proposer des vraies choses quoi garder
espoir
les tous les deux ou pas encore on
essaie on essaye justement le mouvement
qui a été lancée mardi étudiants
fantômes par des étudiants de l1 de
montpellier yasmine fait d'ailleurs
vraiment on pensait pas que ça allait
prendre le thé l'emploi et du coup ça
bravo jeudi qu' il en reste coi ya
encore des gens qui sont gardés les
choses comme ça donne de l'espoir
on espère juste que tout ça ça va amener
quelque chose et pas seulement des
mesures oui on va revenir c'est déjà
bien mais c'est loin d'être suffisant en
fait
merci beaucoup en tout cas d'avoir été
avec nous yona et si longtemps